Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ja, es ist wieder soweit. Es gibt wieder internationale Kurzpässe und ich freue mich, dass wir heute mit der Premier League beginnen. Und da begrüße ich bei mir Thomas Böker, Formtkicker, jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Thomas, hi, schön, dass du wieder mit dabei bist.
Ja, hallo, freut mich auch. Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, es wurde allerhöchste Zeit, mal wieder auf die internationalen Ligen zu blicken. Und da wollen wir heute mit der Premier League beginnen, wobei sich ja so ein bisschen die Frage stellt, Thomas, hat sich denn überhaupt irgendwas getan? Denn wenn ich mir das mal so angucke, den letzten Kurzpass gab es irgendwann im Oktober, da war Liverpool auf 1 und hatte einen großen Vorsprung schon. Jetzt ist der Vorsprung nur noch größer geworden und immer noch keine Niederlage. Was ist da los bei Liverpool? Das ist ja völlig abnormal. 21 Siege, 1 Unentschieden. Ja, und das ist schon die komplette Bilanz dieser 22 Ligaspiele.
Genau, ja. Was sich zum Herbst verändert hat, ist, dass man im Herbst noch nicht zur Meisterschaft gratulieren konnte. Das kann man jetzt. Auch wenn es noch 16 Spiele für Liverpool sind, weil sie noch ein Nachholspiel haben. Aber da wird nichts mehr schiefgehen, weil Ben City ja auch nicht dahinter alles gewinnen wird und Liverpool dementsprechend auch nicht fünf oder sechs Mal noch verlieren wird. Also von daher, natürlich wehrt Jürgen Klopp noch alle Glückwünsche ab, was er da auch sonst machen würde. Er würde ziemlich alt aussehen, wenn es dann doch noch schiefgeht. Aber er muss es halt einfach nur machen, der Form halber. Er wird selber wissen, dass seine Mannschaft das nicht mehr verspielt, weil sie einfach zu gut sind. Und ja, da kann man nur alle Hüte vorziehen, was diese Mannschaft im Prinzip seit mehr als einem Jahr leistet. Die haben ja seit dem 3. Januar 2019 nicht mehr verlogen. Das ist sensationell. Damals 1 zu 2 noch bei Man City. Das war dann so ein leichter Wendepunkt in der vergangenen Saison. Danach hatten sie zwar auch noch Vorsprung, aber dann kam halt Man City. Sensationelle Serie und Liverpool mit dem einen oder anderen Unentschieden zu dem Zeitpunkt noch zu viel. Und ja, jetzt haben sie sich so weit abgesetzt, dass da wirklich nichts mehr schiefgehen kann aus ihrer Sicht. Und das ist halt alles auch kein Zufall, sondern das ist eine sensationell besetzte Mannschaft, die zu dem von Automatismen lebt, schon über, ja, nicht nur jetzt in dieser Saison, sondern schon auch über längeren Zeitraum. Und das wird halt immer besser und man fragt sich wirklich auch, im Blick auf die internationalen Aufgaben jetzt in der Champions League, wer die stoppen soll, weil selbst ein 3-0 für Barca hat ja nicht gereicht im Mai. Und jetzt Atletico Madrid zum Beispiel sehe ich da auch nicht als besonders große Hürde an, zumal die Spanier im Moment auch nicht so gut drauf sind in der Liga. Aber ja, zurück zur Premier League. Liverpool ist halt in allen Belangen der Konkurrenz überlegen und zwischendurch auch nochmal Klubfeldmeister geworden, alles weggesteckt, alle Reisestrapazen und so weiter. Und dann zwischen Boxing Day und Neujahr, wie die anderen auch, ganz normal dreimal gespielt sozusagen und trotzdem alles gewonnen. Und das ist schon klasse. Und jetzt am vergangenen Sonntag, gestern dann die letzte Mannschaft, die sie noch schlagen mussten, weil Manchester United die einzigen waren, die in der Hinrunde zumindest einen Unentschieden abgetrunken haben. Und wenn es so weitergeht, können sie sogar schon im März dann auch rechnerisch Meister sein. Das ist ja gefühlt jetzt schon, aber dann ist auch rechnerisch der Deckel drauf, wenn es so in diesem Rhythmus weitergeht.
Ich finde das so irre, weil natürlich wird es niemandem entgangen sein, was Liverpool da gerade spielt jetzt in den letzten 24 Monaten. Und das sind jetzt eben aktuell bei einem Spiel weniger 16 Punkte Vorsprung auf Manchester City. Aber wenn das selbe jetzt in Manchester City mit Pep Guardiola machen würde, oder wir haben so eine ähnliche Dominanz auch mal vom Barcelona gesehen, wobei da Real Madrid nicht ganz so weit hat abreißen lassen, dann würde man gleich viel darüber sprechen, wie das erzielt wird. Also bei Pep Guardiola ist die Spielphilosophie fast wichtiger, als wie dann eigentlich die Spiele gespielt werden. Das ist zumindest so meine etwas polemische Zuspitzung. Und bei Liverpool habe ich das Gefühl, darüber wird am wenigsten gesprochen. Was würdest du denn sagen? Weil das ist eine Mannschaft, auf die werden wir zurückblicken in zehn Jahren und werden sagen, Wahnsinn, das war einfach das Liverpool von damals. Die haben etwas mit dem Fußball gemacht, die haben ihn verändert, die haben irgendwie den Schlüssel gefunden, im aktuellen Fußball eine solche Farbesaison hinzulegen. Was ist denn der Schlüssel? Wie würdest du es denn beschreiben?
Ja, der Schlüssel ist auch in der Entwicklung zu sehen. Als Klopp vor mittlerweile mehr als vier Jahren nach Liverpool kam, hat er dort das Pressing und Gegenpressing eingeführt. Das deutsche Wort Gegenpressing ist ja sogar in den englischen Fußballsprachgebrauch übergegangen, weil es dafür keinen englischen Begriff gab. Das haben die dann sozusagen von ihm angenommen, als er das mal erklärt hat. Und dann war es auch so, dass das natürlich gut funktioniert hat, aber das war dann natürlich auch nicht der Weisheit, dass es Schluss war. Damit ist man dann auch nicht so dominant gewesen, weil das natürlich auf seine Art schon sehr, sehr gut war, aber eben der Plan B so ein bisschen fehlte. Und das hat man dann auch in den Ergebnissen gemerkt. Meister waren sie sowieso jetzt seitdem noch nicht, aber sie waren auch in den ersten Jahren auch nicht so mit in der Spitze, wie es jetzt dann der Fall ist. Weil eben diese Entwicklung stattgefunden hat, weil sie das Pressing zum einen variieren, also sprich, sie laufen nicht nur total hoch an, sondern es ist auch mal ein Mittelfeld-Pressing dabei und sie sind sogar auch in der Lage, sich komplett in die eigene Hälfte zurückzuziehen, wenn es nötig ist, und dann einfach auch ganz schlicht, muss man sagen, aber nicht im Sinne von einfallslos, sondern im Sinne von schlau, dann in dem Moment, weil es einfach dann das beste Mittel ist, dann einfach mal zu kontern, tief aus der eigenen Hälfte, aber auch das ist ja noch im Prinzip die gleiche Stilform, nur etwas tiefer und sie haben es eben erweitert, auch durch Ballbesitzfußball, der nicht so ausgeprägt ist, Das ist ein Beispiel, wie der bei Man City, aber der auch natürlich logischerweise dann auf einer unglaublichen Ball- und Passsicherheit beruht. Weil er auch eben dann in diesem Fall ein Rätschen ins Sand begreift und die damit auch mittlerweile in der Lage sind, tiefstehende Gegner zu knacken. Manchmal braucht es dafür auch ein bisschen länger. Es gab eine Phase, glaube ich, bis Herbst, da war noch, das hat es noch nie gegeben, dass ein Tabellenführer in England so viele knappe Siege mit einem Torunterschied eingefahren hat. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Liverpool jedes Spiel 5-0 gewonnen hat, sondern da waren auch knappe Dinger dabei, die sich aber dann eben auch, wie gesagt, gegen sehr massiv tiefstehende Gegner mit Geduld erarbeiten mussten. Sie haben dann eben auch die Klasse, aufgrund ihrer drei Superstürmer, in jeder Situation Tor zu erzielen. Und was eben ganz wichtig ist, 14 Gegentore nach 22 Spielen sind natürlich auch einwendig der Schlüssel. Die wissen halt, vorne treffen wir immer irgendwie und ganz oft halten sie die Null oder kriegen nur ein Gegentor, weil sie eben auch den besten Innenverteidiger der Welt im Moment haben mit Van Dijk. Sie haben mit Alisson einen der besten Keeper, den ich persönlich jetzt direkt hinter mal eine Neuer und Marc-Andre Tastegen sehe, mit dem Alisson und das ist schon eine richtig gute Achse. Dazu die beiden Außenverteidiger, die mehr verkappte Flügelstürmer sind, aber eben trotzdem auch ihre Defensivaufgaben nahezu perfekt erledigen. Über die drei vorne ist alles gesagt. Und dann gibt es dazwischen so ein Mittelfeld, wo auch die Besetzungen mal öfter wechseln, wo man jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen würde, das sind Wijnaldum, Henderson oder auch ein Fabinho oder Oxlade-Chamberlain. Das sind auf dem Papier keine Weltklasse-Spieler. Das ist nicht so, dass man jetzt sagen muss, oh wow, Liverpool hat aber das beste Mittelfeld in England oder gar in Europa. Nee, das haben sie gar nicht. Aber die haben das zurzeit zumindest oder seit einigen Monaten schon am besten funktionierendste Mittelfeld, weil da jeder weiß, was er zu tun hat. Weil die alle, wie gesagt, erstmal sehr passsicher sind. Das sind jetzt auch keine schlechten Fußballer, das sind gute Fußballer. Und die eine unglaubliche Laufarbeit verrichten. Und dann eben zwischen dieser Weltklasse Defensive und Offensive das ideale Verbindungsstück darstellen, wenn auch nicht auf dem allerhöchsten Level, wie die jetzt vorne und hinten agieren, aber eben so, dass diese Rädchen dann ausreichend ineinander greifen können.
Ja, das ist schon wirklich irre, wenn man sich einfach mal anhand der Zahlen versucht, zu erschließen, was Liverpool so besonders macht. Also die 14, hast du schon hingewiesen, diese 14 Gegentreffer, das ist mit weitem Abstand die beste Abwehr der Liga dahinter kommt. Erst Sheffield mit 22 Gegentreffer, das sind halt schon mal acht mehr und es ist ja immer noch eine sehr gute Bilanz nach 23 Spielen. Also das ist das eine. Aber dann eben auch das, was du angesprochen hast, es ist eben nicht mehr nur Pressing und Gegenpressing, in Anführungszeichen nur, sondern also durchschnittlich hat Liverpool den zweithöchsten Ballbesitz der Premier League, Manchester City bei 61 Prozent aufgerundet, Liverpool bei 58 Prozent. Und der einzige Unterschied, oder also jetzt ein bisschen überspitzt, der einzige Unterschied, aber der größte Unterschied tatsächlich zu Manchester City ist eigentlich, wie ist das Passspiel aufgezogen? Da gehört Liverpool zu den Mannschaften, die die drittmeisten langen Bälle spielt. Und das ist was, was man bei Manchester City nicht sieht. Da gibt es einen deutlichen Unterschied. Es sind im Schnitt 16 pro Spiel, die Liverpool mehr spielt. Und das allein… Ja, genau, genau. Aber das ist quasi der große Unterschied im Ballbesitz zwischen diesen beiden Mannschaften, die eben am meisten den Ball haben in der Premier League. Ich meine, jeder, der gegen Liverpool spielt, weiß auch, was auf ihn zukommt. Und das finde ich so interessant. Also, dass eben lange Bälle ist einer der Unterschiede. Die Art und Weise, wie Zweiecke kämpfe, geführt werden, ist ein Unterschied. Es ist auch unheimlich faszinierend, wie wenige gelbe Karten eigentlich Liverpool bisher erst gesammelt hat. 23 gelbe Karten, einen Platzverweis gab es. Zum Vergleich eben wie der Manchester City, 41 gelbe Karten und zwei Platzverweise, also deutlich mehr. 18 gelbe Karten mehr in den wenigen Spielen, die es bisher gab. Also, das ist schon interessant. Und eben das, was du gesagt hast mit den Spielern, wenn ich noch mal zum herauszustellen. Ich habe mir einfach mal die Transferbilanz aller Vereine, seitdem Jürgen Klopp in der Premier League ist, herausgelassen. Und wenn man sich dann die Transferseiden anguckt, dann hat Manchester City da am meisten ausgegeben. Die haben ein Transferseido von – also alles jetzt laut transfermarkt.de, nicht an der einzelnen Million aufhängen, aber grundsätzlich kann man sich daran orientieren – von 670 Millionen investierten Euro nach quasi auch schon Abzug aller Einnahmen, die man hatte. Manchester United 480 Millionen Euro. Und Liverpool kommt in dieser Tabelle, in der 25 Mannschaften sind, erst auf Platz 15. Es gibt 14 Mannschaften – und da sind Stoke City dabei – Watford, West Ham, Aston Villa, Bournemouth, die mehr investiert haben, wenn wir uns das Transferseido angucken, seitdem Jürgen Klopp in der Liga ist. Das Transfer minus bei Liverpool über diesen Zeitraum von 2015, 2016 bis heute sind 121 Millionen Euro. Und das, finde ich, ist so das, was nicht in unsere Zeit zu passen scheint. Uns wird immer so geriert, als ob es halt so die Superstars sind, die man holen muss.
Ja, ja. Es zeigt halt, dass es eine gewachsene Mannschaft ist. Auf der anderen Seite, bei dieser Transferbilanz muss man aber auch fairerweise dazu sagen, da ist auch der Coutinho-Transfer macht einiges aus, denke ich. Zu Barca, ich glaube, 120 Millionen Warns oder so, das darf man natürlich auch gegeneinander aufrechnen. Man sollte das halt noch nicht vergessen. Also sprich, auch Liverpool hat deutlich mehr, wenn man jetzt mal den internationalen Vergleich heranzieht, in diesen viereinhalb Jahren deutlich mehr investiert, zum Beispiel als Bayern. Nur, um da auch mal eine Gewichtung zu kriegen. Es mag sein, dass sie in der Premier League da letztlich auf Platz 15 sind, nach Abzug aller Konzerts in beide Richtungen. Aber das ist natürlich trotzdem noch ein ganz anderes Level, als wir es hier selbst vom deutschsten, reichsten Verein gewohnt sind. Und deswegen darf man das im internationalen Vergleich nicht aus Acht lassen, aber es ändert nichts daran, wie gesagt, dass da punktuell sich verstärkt wird, dass da mit Sinn und Verstand eingekauft wird und nicht nur um das Kaufenswillen. Zum Beispiel vor dieser Saison, wir haben die Champions League gewonnen, da könnte man ja sagen, so, jetzt muss frisches Blut her, weil jetzt sind die satt. Nee, im Gegenteil, die hatten das ganz große Ziel, mehr noch als alles andere, leicht die Stadt ja danach erstmals seit 1990 wieder Meister zu werden. Und genau das wird jetzt der Stadt und den Fans und allen möglichen Leuten dort in Liverpool eben erfüllt, dieser Wunsch 2020. Danach sieht es aus. Und das ist was, was man da auch eben richtig eingeschätzt hat. Natürlich wäre auch das Geld da gewesen, noch den einen oder anderen Superstar zu kaufen. Den hätte man mit Sicherheit auch erfolgreich eingebaut. Aber Klopp und alle anderen haben eben entschieden, dem vorhandenen Kader zu vertrauen und dementsprechend dann zahlen die Jungs da entsprechend dann auch zurück jetzt.
Wahnsinn. Aber dann lass mal auch einen Blick auf den Verfolger werfen. Denn das, was Liverpool so herausragend macht, nämlich keine Punkte abzugeben bei nur einem Unentschieden aus 22 Spielen, genau das passiert bei Manchester City in der viel größeren Häufung, als man es jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre gesehen hat. Manchester City hat jetzt in 23 Spielen schon dreimal Unentschieden gespielt und fünfmal sogar schon verloren. Das heißt, acht Spiele, in denen man nicht gewinnen konnte, das wäre eine vollkommen normale Bilanz, wenn es jetzt eben nicht das Manchester City von Pep Guardiola wäre, das ja auch gezeigt hat in den letzten zwei Jahren, wie dominant man seinerseits die Liga bespielen kann. Was ist denn deine Diagnose, woran liegt es bei City, dass es in dieser Saison nicht sein soll?
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Gründe meiner Ansicht nach. Die haben ja diesen Sättigungsgrad, den ich gerade bei Liverpool von sprach, den haben die auf eine gewisse Weise und das ist, glaube ich, völlig menschlich. Wenn man zwei solche herausragende Spielzeiten hinter sich hat, haben die so ein bisschen auch national, glaube ich, erreicht. Also es ist nicht so, dass das hat nichts mit fehlenden Billen zu tun oder sonst was. Im Gegenteil, die wollen auch weiter jedes Spiel gewinnen. Aber das ist schon, glaube ich, bei denen so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf, dass das eben auch schwer zu toppen ist. Letztes Jahr waren es 98 Punkte, davor waren es 100 Punkte. Das waren schon sensationelle Marken und das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Liverpool höchst wahrscheinlich oder wenn sie diesen Trend fortsetzen, diese Saison sogar noch toppen können. Aber sprich, die haben Großes geleistet, Man City, sind aber immer relativ früh aus der Champions League ausgeschieden. Seit Tep da ist noch nicht einmal das Halbfinale erreicht. Vielleicht läuft dieses Jahr ein bisschen anders, wobei der Real Madrid natürlich das schwierigste los ist, was man als Gruppensieger bekommen konnte fürs Achtelfinale. Das ist ja Pech, dann real rauszuziehen aus dem Topf der Gruppen 2. Aber da sehe ich vielleicht dann auch mehr Chancen, dass sie sich irgendwann auf diesen Titel konzentrieren können, weil auch Guardiola wird wissen, dass die Meisterschaft weg ist. So wenig wie Klopp sagen kann, sie ist schon gewonnen, kann er natürlich sich hinstellen und sagen, das war's, weil das wäre natürlich auch kontraproduktiv. Aber im Grunde weiß er es und wichtig ist, dass er jetzt dann auch nachhandelt, sprich dann eben, die den Stars auch mal eine Pause gönnt, wenn es dann nicht mehr sein muss, weil sie werden weder Meister noch werden sie aus den Top 4 rausrutschen, also so oder so nächstes Jahr Champions League. Und ja, da vielleicht dann den Fokus jetzt dann auf die Königsklasse legen. Also das ist das eine, dass vielleicht da so ein gewisser, nicht mehr die allerletzte Motivation vielleicht für die Premier League da war. Dann muss man sagen, wenn das so aus dem eigenen Verein kommt, dann klingt das ja immer so ein bisschen nach Ausreden, aber auch als objektiver Betrachter muss man einfach sagen, dass sie wahnsinniges Pech haben. Es gibt keine Mannschaft und vor allem keine Top-Mannschaft in England, die seit es den Videobeweis gibt, dermaßen Pech hat mit den Entscheidungen. Entweder greift der Videoassistent gar nicht ein, wenn es nötig wäre, oder er korrigiert richtige Entscheidungen ins falsche oder was weiß ich, alle möglichen Konstellationen, die man sich vorstellen kann. Unter denen hat man City tatsächlich schon gelitten und das ist dann auch keine Ausrede, sondern das ist von Vereinsseite, das ist tatsächlich ein Fakt, dass sie da wahnsinniges Pech haben. Dann haben sie mit Abstand in der Liga, habe ich jetzt gestern noch nachgeschaut, die meisten Pfosten- und Landentreffer, nämlich 17 Stück, da kommt Norwich auf Platz 2 mit 10 Treffern und Liverpool hat, glaube ich, 7 oder 8. Auch das ist ein Ausdruck natürlich nicht von fehlender Qualität, sondern einfach, das sind dann die berühmten Zentimeter, die fehlen. Aber es ist nicht nur Pech, sondern es sind ein Haufen individueller Fehler gemacht worden. Genau das, was du sagst, man ist nicht von denen gewohnt. Aber auch es gibt Gründe, die dazu geführt haben, nämlich dass eben mit Company der Abwehrchef weg ist, der war zwar kein Stammspieler mehr, aber der war unheimlich wichtig von seiner Persönlichkeit her und für den Zusammenhalt der ganzen Truppe. Und wenn er gespielt hat, dann logischerweise auch auf dem Platz in der Innenverteidigung. Und dann kam noch dazu Laporte, auch nach wenigen Wochen Spieltagen verletzt. Der fehlt bis heute, der kommt jetzt langsam wieder zurück, vielleicht nächste Woche im FA Cup wieder dabei. Aber das war dann einfach in der Kombination zu viel. Und dann stößt selbst so ein Kader wie Man City mit den Defensivleuten an Grenzen. Und die haben sich unfassbare Böcke geleistet. Beispielen gegen Norwich und gegen Wilfer Hemden, wo sie schon geführt haben. Und teilweise und dann noch verloren haben. Also das sind Niederlagen, die hatte man so nie auf dem Zettel, das hat man von denen nicht gekannt. Und ja, dementsprechend in der Summe kommt das dabei raus. Und jetzt haben sie nur bei zwei der letzten 13 Ligaspielen zu Null gespielt. Das ist alles kein Zufall, weil auch Ederson, der ja auch zwischenzeitlich sogar gar nicht gespielt hat, aber der auch nicht mehr die Form der Meisterjahre hat. Das sind einige der Gründe, die eben dazu geführt haben, dass diese Mannschaft die mit Sicherheit nicht schlechter Fußball spielt als in den letzten zwei Jahren, was ihre Spielanlage und so weiter angeht. Aber es kommt halt alles dann zusammen. Und Leroy Zanés Ausfall nicht zu vergessen. Auch wenn er möglicherweise ja damals auf dem Sprung, im August, auf dem Sprung zu Bayern schon war, als er sich verletzte, sprich sowieso nicht mehr eigentlich die Rolle gespielt hat, die ihm ja aus deutscher Sicht dort vielleicht zugestanden hätte, weil er ja eigentlich, wenn er gespielt hat, immer meistens sehr gut war. Aber bei Pep irgendwie nicht mehr so das Standing hatte. Dementsprechend sollte er eigentlich gehen. Dann kamen die Verletzungen und jetzt wäre natürlich froh der Verein, wenn er ihn im Moment noch als Alternative hätte, weil das macht sich natürlich bemerkbar auch für den Sterling, der nicht jetzt mehr als 20 Spiele in der Liga plus Champions League zu dem Zeitpunkt immer auf absolut höchstem Niveau spielen kann. Selbst ein Aguero, der jetzt auch schon wieder 15 Mal getroffen hat diese Saison, der kann es auch nicht alleine richten und so weiter. Wie gesagt, die haben es alle nicht verlernt, aber es kommen eben jetzt dann auch ein paar Schwächen mal dazu, die vielleicht völlig normal sind, auch für so eine Mannschaft, die man von ihnen nicht kannte und die deswegen jetzt so auffällig sind und in der Summe oder in dem Zusammenspiel mit Liverpools unglaublicher Serie jetzt so sehr ins Gewicht fallen.
Ja, und wer weiß, ob da vielleicht auch manchmal dann das eine, das andere verstärkt, gerade weil City schon sehr früh in der Saison gesehen hat, jetzt sind es schon drei Punkte, jetzt sind es schon fünf Punkte, summiert sich das dann vielleicht nochmal besonders hoch. Aber so ist es dann halt. Aber auf das Achtelfinale gegen Real Madrid, da kann man sich schon freuen als neutrale Beobachter. Ende Februar ist das Hinspiel und dann Mitte März das Rückspiel. Das Achtelfinale ist ja so schön aufgeteilt in der Champions League. Wenn ich auf die Tabelle gucke, dann wundert mich Platz 1 und Platz 2 gar nicht. Liverpool und City, nur die Entfernung zwischen den beiden kann einen da noch verwundern. Das haben wir jetzt geklärt. Was allerdings dann schon etwas verwunderlich ist, ist Leicester City, die auf Tabellenplatz 3 kommen aktuell. Es sind auch nur drei Punkte hinter Leicester City. Und noch viel wichtiger, nach hinten hin hat man 11 Punkte Vorsprung, gerade auf Manchester United, auf dem Europa League Platz. Das heißt aktuell läst er auf Champions League Kurs mit einem überragenden Jamie Vardy. Aber ich vermute mal, das wird jetzt nicht der einzige Grund sein, warum die da oben stehen. Oder wie würdest du das einschätzen?
Nö, nicht der einzige Grund. Aber 17 Tore von Vardy sind natürlich auch wenig. Von 48. Also sprich, wenn man die mal abziehen und dann in den einzelnen Spielen werden die teilweise auch für die entsprechenden Punkte gesorgt haben. Das waren wahrscheinlich nicht nur Bonustore, sondern auch ganz wichtige Tore. Dann ist Vardy natürlich nicht der einzige, aber schon ein sehr gewichtiger Grund. Ein weiterer ist Trainer Brendan Rodgers, der ja, ist ein bisschen fähig, über ihn zu reden. Insofern, also ich habe zum Beispiel eine große Sympathie für Celtic in Schottland. Und ja, alle Celtic-Anhänger, weiß ich auch dort, von unserem Korrespondenten, die sind natürlich, die haben einen riesen Hals auf den, weil er den Verein mehr oder weniger im Stich gelassen hat, als das vor einem Jahr da das Angebot aus Leicester kam. Das wird vertraglich schon alles in Ordnung gewesen sein und so weiter. Aber trotzdem hat er natürlich einen, ja, den schottischen Vorzeigeklub dann von heute auf morgen verlassen. Das war nicht so die feine Art, aber er wollte sich natürlich auch noch mal in der Premier League beweisen und ist ja mit Liverpool vor ein paar Jahren Vizemeister geworden. Und jetzt wollte das natürlich noch mal allen zeigen, dass er aus einem – ja, das ist Leicester, Leicester war, wenn man das Meisterjahr 2016 ausrechnet – natürlich im Grunde eine Durchschnittsmannschaft immer, was nicht negativ gemeint ist, sondern es ist halt einfach so. Und die jetzt noch mal in die Champions League zu führen, das ist natürlich ein Riesenerfolg. Da sind sie auf dem besten Weg. Und der Schlüssel ist, dass er zum Beispiel auch sehr mutig spielen lässt, sehr offensiv, nach vorne orientiert das Ganze. Sprich, da ist nichts irgendwie – oder Ranieri damals im Meisterjahr war es ja eigentlich so, langer Ball auf Vardy, zweiter Ball, dann noch mal auf Vardy, so ungefähr, und er war drin. So war ungefähr das Strickmuster bei ganz vielen Toren von Leicester. Und jetzt ist es schon sehr viel variabler. Auch wenn letztlich Vardy immer noch der – oder wieder jetzt der Vollstrecker ist. Aber da ist mit Madison zum Beispiel auf der 10 eine Riesenqualität. Dann ist auch über die Abwehrschmeiche 2.16, die heute, ein toller Rückhalt. Man darf nicht vergessen, sie haben Maguire verloren an Manchester United und haben diesen Abgang erfolgreich kompensiert. Der Ex-Freiburger Seyüntü spielte auch, muss ich sagen, wenn man den einen oder anderen Bock aus Freiburg von ihm noch vor Augen hat, spielt er eine erstaunlich gute Rolle dort. Ist auch Stammspieler. Und Telemann zum Beispiel ist auch eine ganz wichtige Rolle in dem Team. Sprich, das ist eine gute Mischung aus erfahrenen Spielern. Der Ex-Schalker Christian Fuchs, der eigentlich auch schon fast weg vom Fenster war, ist mittlerweile wieder etabliert. Und ja, so ist da einiges entstanden. Und man muss ja sagen, sie hatten ja als Verein das schreckliche Erlebnis, dass der Besitzer dort gestorben ist vor, ich glaube, jetzt mehr als einem Jahr war es bei dem Hubschrauberabsturz. Und das hat den Verein natürlich erstmal eine Schockstarre versetzt, aber auch auf eine gewisse Art auch zusammenrücken lassen. Und aus dieser Katastrophe, tatsächlichen Katastrophe – im Sport spricht man öfter davon, aber das war wirklich eine – ist man jetzt dann so hervorgegangen, dass man geschlossen ist und danach einfach auch noch mal vielleicht auch ihm zu ehren und ihm zu liebe sich dann noch mal so zusammengetan hat, dass man noch mal was ganz besonderes erreichen will und da ist man auf einem richtig guten Weg.
Also absolut faszinierende Saison von Leicester City, nur um das noch mal einzuordnen, weil wir erinnern uns natürlich an die Meisterschaft im Jahr 15, 16 oder in der Saison 15, 16. Die anderen Platzierungen seitdem waren einmal ein zwölfter Platz, einmal ein neunter Platz und nochmal ein neunter Platz. Das heißt, es hat sich jetzt nicht gerade angedeutet, so wie es jetzt zumindest Stand jetzt 23. Spieltag gerade aussieht. Dahinter wartet dann eine Mannschaft, Thomas, auf die auch die deutschen Fußballfans wahrscheinlich etwas genauer blicken werden, denn da haben wir einen der Champions League-Gegner in der nächsten Runde, nämlich den FC Chelsea. Was ist denn zu Chelsea festzuhalten, die mit Platz 4 und 39 Punkten von außen betrachtet, würde ich sagen, absolut im Soll liegen?
Ja, die liegen ihren Möglichkeiten entsprechend im Soll. Man muss sagen, dass acht Niederlagen natürlich auch kein besonders gutes Zeugnis für die Konkurrenz darstellen, weil man mit acht Niederlagen nach 23 Spielen auf Platz 4 ist. Aber letztlich, für sich betrachtet, machen sie es gut, machen sie es ordentlich, haben sehr, sehr viele junge Spieler einbauen müssen, aber auch wollen, dass er noch verstärkter auf die Jugend setzt, als es jetzt allein durch die Transfersperre begründet gewesen wäre. Diese Transfersperre ist übrigens jetzt schon hinfällig im laufenden Monat. Trotzdem ist da jetzt noch nichts groß gekommen, aber das trifft im Moment für alle Vereine zu, einfach weil es wahrscheinlich europaweit wenige gibt, die einem woanders weiterhelfen bzw. die von guten Clubs auch ziehen gelassen werden. So wie jetzt zum Beispiel Erling Haaland, das ist natürlich ein Sonderfall, der als Dortmund jetzt zugreifen konnte. Aber solche Transfers gibt es halt im Winter nicht. Chelsea dürfte jetzt wieder welche tätigen, Geld ist bekanntlich auch da. Aber sie haben es jetzt noch nicht gemacht und muss man mal abwarten, ob sich da noch was tut. Aber im Grunde leistet Lampard da schon sehr gute, ja man muss es so nennen, eigentlich Entwicklungsarbeit mit Rhys James, mit Mason Mount, mit Hudson O'Doy, mit Tammy Abraham sowieso, Pulisic auch noch sehr jung. Das sind alles Spieler, die ja großes Potential haben, die sich alle noch entwickeln und denen man entsprechend natürlich auch dann diese Rückschläge, wie jetzt zum Beispiel am Wochenende 0 zu 1 spät in Newcastle verloren und trotz Überlegenheit auch kein Tor gemacht. Ich war selber am Boxing Day in London und habe mir Chelsea Southampton im Stadion privat angeschaut und war da auch nicht enttäuscht von Chelsea, weil sie da absolut Durchschnittskraft und auch esprie im Spiel nach vorne war. Das war kaum anzuschauen. Kurz vorher hatten sie aber zum Beispiel in Tottenham gewonnen und richtig gut gespielt. Sie sind ja auch im Champions League-Acht-Finale auf Bayern, also eine schwierige Gruppe mit Valencia und Ajax überstanden und auch ein bisschen Glück dabei, aber auch richtig gut gespielt zwischenzeitlich. Sprich, diese Leistungsschwankungen nach oben und nach unten sind sehr bemerkenswert in dieser Saison, diese Ausschläge dort. Es gibt eigentlich selten Mittelmaßes, die sind wieder richtig gut oder richtig schlecht. Das macht es in der Vorbereitung für Bayern sehr schwierig, weil sie auch schwierig auszurechnen sind vom System. Sie variieren da oft zwischen Dreier- und Viererkette in der Abwehr. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sie gegen Bayern gerade daheim im ersten Spiel, wo es darum geht, für sie auch zur Null zu spielen, kein Auswärtstor zuzulassen, dass sie da auch sehr kompakt stehen werden. Da sind sie auch wieder sicherer, seit Antonio Rüdiger wieder dabei ist, der lange gefehlt hat, der deutsche Nationalspieler. Das kann dann schwierig werden für Bayern, da eine Lücke zu finden. Da muss man bei Kortland immer extrem aufpassen. Auf der anderen Seite ist das dann natürlich schon eher auf Sicherung bedacht. Dann sind die Angriffe nach vorne auch eher seltener. Wenn Bayern den Ballbesitz Fußball zeigen und aufziehen kann, dann besteht eine ganz gute Chance, auch in London für eine gute Ausnahmsposition zu sorgen. Aber wie gesagt, Chelsea ist eine Wundertüte. Ich würde nicht ausschließen, wenn sie so spielen, wie man sie schon einige Male erlebt hat, dass Bayern da richtig klar gewinnt. Ich würde aber auch nicht ausschließen, dass wenn sie ihr Potenzial abrufen und dann mit den vielen jungen Spielern Tempo-Fußball aufziehen können – und da hat Bayern ja bekanntlich auch schon Probleme, wie oft sie ausgecountert wurden – dann kann es auch in die andere Richtung laufen. Das Spiel vorher zu sagen, das wird sehr, sehr schwierig.
Wir haben es ja auch schon häufiger erlebt, dass es die eine Umstellung des Gegners sein kann, die dann Bayern vor Probleme stellt. Und wenn du davon sprichst, dass Chelsea sehr flexibel spielt – das war ja gar nicht immer so bei Chelsea der Fall – dann kann man darauf, glaube ich, auch gespannt sein. Das sind die Top 4 jetzt gewesen. Welche Mannschaften findest du denn jetzt noch wichtig erwähnenswert? Wir können leider nicht über alle 20 sprechen. Auch wenn ich so wichtig einschätze, hättest du mir zu jeder tatsächlich eine interessante Geschichte zu erzählen. Aber pick dir gerne mal selber raus, wen würdest du denn noch kurz erwähnen gerne jetzt?
Ja, wenn wir schon über den einen deutschen Gegner gesprochen haben mit Chelsea, sollten wir den anderen nicht vernachlässigen. Also Tottenhemm, die ja auf RB Leipzig treffen werden im Achtelfinale. Die sind jetzt Achter, stagnieren so ein bisschen auch unter – jetzt nach dem Trainerwechsel Torse Mourinho hat in den ersten Wochen da erwartungsgemäß natürlich für frischen Wind gesorgt auf seine Art. Aber sie leiden im Moment natürlich extrem so runter, dass Harry Kane fehlt. Klar war sehr viel auf ihn zugestimmt, aber er hat dann auch immer die Tore gemacht, ausrechenbar hin oder her. Er hat die Dinger dann halt auch reingemacht. Das war so ein bisschen Son und Muga, die auch richtig gute Stürmer sind. Aber das geht ihnen dann halt ab, diese Kahlschneuzigkeit und diese Effizienz. In dem Maße, wie Kain die hat, haben die sie eben nicht. Das hat man vor allem gesehen, als sie gegen Liverpool verloren haben. Die waren richtig nah dran am Unentschieden oder sogar von den Chancen, der hätten das Spiel sogar gewinnen können. Und Liverpool hätte sich an dem Tag nicht beschweren dürfen. Aber da war dann eben kein Kain vorne. Der wird auch gegen Leipzig noch zweimal fehlen bis in den April hinein. Hinzu kommt Cissoukos, Ausfall im Mittelfeld tut ihnen richtig weh. Der Weltmeistertorwart Ugo Luriz war jetzt auch verletzt, kommt jetzt langsam zurück. Aber diese Automatismen greifen dann auch nicht so richtig. Da ist auch dann Knatsch um Ericsson, wo jetzt der Wechsel zu Inter Mailand erwartet wird. Und der jetzt dann auch für Tottenham keinen Verlust mehr darstellt, zu wehren, den letzten Wochen dann gespielt hat. Oder meistens gespielt hat, nicht immer. Aber es hat schon sehr nachgelassen, auch wenn man ihn noch vor Augen hat. Vor der WM mit Dänemark zum Beispiel war es viel besser. Also ich denke, dass Leipzig in der jetzigen Form durchaus Favorit ist gegen Tottenham. Und das will natürlich was heißen gegen den Champions League Vorjahresfinalisten. Aber sie sind eben auch nicht mehr so gut wie im vergangenen Frühjahr. Und sie müssen sehen, dass sie in der Premier League, das sind dann auch schon acht Punkte Rückstand auf Chelsea. Ob sie die Lücke noch mal schließen, weiß ich nicht, ist sehr, sehr schwierig. Ich glaube, dass sie vielleicht dann in den Pokalwettbewerben da eher noch eine Chance haben, Titel zu holen. Irgendwas geht ja bei Mourinho immer. Aber Champions League glaube ich eher nicht. Da werden sie sich sehr schwer tun gegen Leipzig.
So hört es sich in der Tat an. Wir konnten ja Tottenham tatsächlich auch schon unter Mourinho in der Gruppenphase gegen die Bayern sehen, auch wenn das Spiel von der Tabellenkonstellation her nicht mehr entscheidend war, was es da gab. Was hat denn Mourinho verändert bei Tottenham im Vergleich zu Pochettino?
Ja, er klingt eigentlich gar nicht nach Mourinho, aber er hat in den ersten Spielen tatsächlich viel offensiver auftreten lassen.
Nee, klingt echt nicht nach Mourinho.
Ja, war aber so. Viel mutiger, viel frischer. Aber es klingt nicht nach Mourinho und die Ergebnisse waren dann auch nicht Mourinho-like. Da waren erstmal viele Spiele, auch wenn sie gewonnen haben, 3-2 oder so in der Art oder 4-2, sprich immer einige mit zwei Gegentoren dabei. Das hat sich so ein bisschen jetzt stabilisiert, aber nach vorne ist eben – man hat es in den letzten drei Spielen überhaupt nicht getroffen und haben jetzt auch vier Ligaspiele nicht gewonnen. Und ja, das summiert sich dann eben, dass da auch – es ist schon besser geworden, weil unter Pochettino lief halt überhaupt nichts mehr. Aber es hat nicht die entscheidende Wende gegeben, die man sich wahrscheinlich kurzfristig erworfen hat. Langfristig muss man auch da sehen, was Transfer ist, jetzt vielleicht auch im Winter, spätestens dann aber im Sommer bewirken. Und dann wird man dann fairerweise auch erst mal in New York letztlich abschließend dort bewerten können.
Und das ist ja – das ist dann schon mal eine Sache, die sich bei Tottenham verändert hat in der Transferpolitik. War man ja tatsächlich – die Ausnahme mit sehr, sehr wenigen Investitionen hing auch mit dem Stadiumbau zusammen und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist Tottenham Gegner von Leipzig. Über wen würdest du sagen, lohnt es jetzt auch noch ein paar Minuten zu investieren in diesem Kurzpass?
Ja, wenn wir schon mal alle Großen dann fast durch haben, sollten wir ganz kurz FC Arsenal erwähnen.
Sind die noch ein Großer, ja?
Ja, vom Nachhinein sollten wir, aber sie sind halt jetzt nur noch 10. Oder seit einer Weile schon 10. Die haben 11 mal unentschieden gespielt. Das ist natürlich dann viel zu wenig. Wir haben jetzt auch unter Ateter zum dritten Mal – der neuen Trainer Nikola Ateter – zum dritten Mal Führung nicht zum Sieg gereicht, diesmal gegen Sheffield. Neulich müssen sie auch noch auf Obermeyangarde verzichten, der ja da neulich sich das üble Foul gegen Max Meyer geleistet hat. Er spricht ihren besten Torjäger, können sie auch nicht mal einfach so ersetzen. Da lief halt schon vieles unter Una Emery schief. Da waren taktische und personelle Entscheidungen, die man überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehen konnte. Da muss einiges aufgearbeitet werden, jetzt zum neuen Trainer, was eben auch nicht von heute auf morgen geht. Letztlich, glaube ich, ist es bei Arsenal dann auch immer so ein ja überall über fußballisches Können muss man bei denen nicht reden. Auch bei jungen Spielern, die jetzt rankommen, wie Martinelli zum Beispiel oder so. Das ist schon gut, da ist schon Potenzial da, aber das braucht zum einen Zeit. Zum anderen gibt es dann aber auch immer so ein ein bisschen ein Mentalitätsproblem in dem Sinne, dass sie ja die beißen nie so richtig. Also wenn es läuft, dann läuft es. Dann ist das auch richtig schön anzusehen. Aber es gibt selten Spiele, die Arsenal drehen kann und wo sie sich richtig in ein Spiel kämpfen, beißen können, so wie das zum Beispiel auch Chelsea oder Tottenham an schlechten Tagen vielleicht mal gelingt. Das vermisst man dort und muss man schauen, ob das in irgendeiner Form sich entwickelt. Mesut Özil war ja schon mal völlig weg vom Fenster. Mittlerweile spielt er wieder, wird jetzt dann auch da bleiben. Aber letztlich ist er auch so ein bisschen windbildlich für das, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Wenn es läuft, dann läuft es. Dann gibt es auch immer noch wenige Zehner, die einen schöneren Ball spielen als er. Vom rein fußballerischen, ästhetischen her. Aber wenn es nicht läuft, dann ist er aber auch der erste, der sich versteckt und auch versteckt bleibt. So laufen dann eben sinnbildlich und vom Spiegelbild her die ganzen Arsenal-Spiele dann auch in der Regel ab.
Die Statistik zu dem, was du gesagt hast, geht folgendermaßen. 13 Mal lag Arsenal in 23 Liga-Spielen zurück und man hat nur 2 Mal danach noch gewonnen. Da kurz als Gegenpol der ewige FC Liverpool. Die lagen eh erstmal schon mal nur 4 Mal zurück. Also nicht 13 Mal, sondern 4 Mal. Und die haben kein einziges Mal tatsächlich dann auch verloren. Wissen wir ja. Sie sind ja immer noch unbesiegt in dieser Saison. Also das ist das, was du so ein bisschen angesprochen hast. Hört sich ehrlich gesagt so an wie immer bei Arsenal in den letzten Jahren. Die Namen sind sogar halbwegs gleich geblieben, außer die des Trainers. Der hat sich jetzt nochmal verändert. Aber ansonsten scheint das da irgendwie so in einem Stadium der Mittelmäßigkeit gefangen zu sein. Auf einem so hohen Niveau, dass man dann trotzdem nicht mittelmäßig ist. Das ist jetzt die Ausnahme, dass man auch wirklich Zehnther ist. Aber im Vergleich zu den anderen Top-Clubs mittelmäßig.
Ja und es scheint ein KS-Lauf zu sein. Und da kommen wir dann gleich vielleicht noch kurz zum nächsten Verein, Manchester United. Die sind zwar jetzt aktuell fünfter. Also ein paar Plätze besser und auch eine Perspektive bei fünf Punkten Rückschritte auf Chelsea besser. Und haben sich auch gestern in Liverpool gar nicht schlecht verkauft. Hätten vielleicht auch höher zurückliegen können, aber hatten dann auch so ein – zwischenzeitlich auch mal kurz die Chance aufs 1-1 und haben auch richtig gut und mutig reingefunden im Spiel. Aber auch da fehlt aktuell die Konstanz. Da fehlt auch eine offensive Spielidee von Zolskjaer, der mal so lichte Momente hat und taktische Eingebungen und Ideen, wo es dann richtig gut läuft, wie zum Beispiel, als sie das Derby bei City gewonnen haben. Aber im Großen und Ganzen fehlt da so ein bisschen der Glanz und vor allem diese Selbstverständlichkeit, die diesen Verein über Jahre ausgemacht und ausgezeichnet haben. Und was ich meine mit dem Kreislauf ist eben, ja, keine Champions League, keine Stars, keine Stars, keine Champions League. Und das wird dann sehr, sehr schwierig, das irgendwann zu durchbrechen. Und wenn man sich Manchester United anschaut, ja, nennen wir einen Weltklasse-Spieler dort im Moment von seinem Potenzial her vielleicht Pogba, aber erstens ist der schon länger verletzt und zweitens hat er genug mit sich selbst zu tun. Und Rushford kann vielleicht mal einer werden. Ja, und dann wird es ehrlich gesagt schon schwierig. Und wir sprechen von Manchester United, immer noch dem englischen Rekordmeister, was sich übrigens auch am Ende dieser Saison nicht ändern wird, weil sonst steht es immer noch 20 zu 19 mutmaßlich, wenn Liverpool Meister wird. Aber, ja, was ich sagen will, es muss nicht mehr lange so bleiben. Sie laufen Gefahr, diesen Status zu verlieren. Da muss man ganz gehörig aufpassen. Es ist eben seit oder nach Alex Ferguson viel versucht worden und insgesamt wenig richtig gemacht worden. Geld spielt da keine Rolle, aber welcher Superstar will schon in der Europa League spielen? Das Problem haben sie aktuell. Für die ist es ganz, ganz wichtig, noch vierter zu werden, um aus diesem Teufelskreis auszubrechen.
Und das Ganze jetzt ohne Markus Reschford, der beste Torschütze bei United mit 14 Treffen in 22 Spielen. Der hat sich jetzt eine Rückenverletzung zugezogen. Und so, wie es ich mitkommen hatte, hat er schon eine ganze Weile mit Schmerzen und auch schon angedeuteten Verletzungen gespielt. Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen in einer schlimmeren Verletzung gemündet. Mindestens sechs Wochen wird er wohl ausfehlen. Das war eh schon keine angenehme Situation bei United. Denn zu den fünf Punkten, die man Rückstand hat auf Chelsea, gehört ja auch, dass man punktgleich mit den Wolverhampton Wanderers gerade auf Platz 5 liegt. Also nicht mal die Europa League wäre gerade sicher. Da muss man eher nach hinten gucken als nach oben. Das ist schon United eben. Wollen wir noch über Ralph Hasenhüttl und den FC Southampton sprechen, Thomas?
Ja, genau. Vielleicht abschließend als letzten Verein, die Saints noch mit ins Boot nehmen. Die haben eine ganz erstaunliche Entwicklung genommen. Letztes Jahr, als Ralph Hasenhüttl kam, hat er sich erst mal bravourös und auch recht zügig im Verhältnis gesehen vor dem Abstieg gerettet. Das war schon mal eine große Leistung. Dann war er eigentlich recht optimistisch, dass man sich so Richtung gesichertes Mittelfeld orientieren kann, ohne dabei natürlich die Stärke der Liga aus den Augen zu verlieren. Sie mussten ein sehr tiefes Tal durchschreiten bis dahin, lange in ärgsten Abstiegsnöten und vor allem 0 zu 9 daheim in der Hinrunde gegen Leicester verloren. Das war unfassbar. Aber Hasenhüttl ist geblieben. Hasenhüttl durfte bleiben. Das allein zeigt, welches Vertrauen der Verein in seine Arbeit und in diese Person Hasenhüttl hat, sprich, dass er auch was entwickeln kann und will und dafür auch der Richtige ist. Und dann die Antwort war dann eben, dass man sich stabilisiert hat wieder. Man hat nicht sofort alles danach gewonnen. Aber man hatte zum Beispiel zwei im Anschluss und dieses 0 zu 9. Zwei Spiele einmal im Pokal, einmal in der Meisterschaft gegen Man City. Hat die beide nur knapp verloren. Das hätte natürlich auch ganz anders ausgehen können, gerade mit so einem Background, wenn man da gerade so untergegangen ist. Das waren schon die ersten Anzeichen dafür, dass sie sich stabilisiert haben. Jetzt haben sie in der Zwischenzeit gegen Chelsea gewonnen, gegen Tottenham gewonnen. Und jetzt am Wochenende haben sie zwar mal wieder verloren, aber nach sechs Spielen, von denen sie fünf gewonnen hatten, also richtig, richtig guten Lauf hatten, haben sie sich befreit. Und wichtig ist, eines dieser siegreichen Spiele war das Rückspiel jetzt in Leicester. Nach dem 0-9 zu Hause haben sie letzte Woche dann in Leicester 2-1 gewonnen. Und das alleine zeigt natürlich die Entwicklung, die man da genommen hat. Es wurden rund ums Stadion in Leicester T-Shirts verkauft mit dem Aufdruck 0-9. Und das war natürlich dann nochmal eine extra Motivation für Southampton. Aber die hätte es gar nicht gebraucht. Hartenhütter hat gesagt, wir wollten einfach zeigen, was seit diesem Spiel bei uns passiert ist, wie wir uns entwickelt haben. Dass man sich gegen diesen drohenden Absturz, der durchaus der Mannschaft kann, an so einem Ergebnis komplett zerbrechen. Das hat nicht stattgefunden. Das spricht zum einen, wie gesagt, für den Trainer, zum anderen für den Charakter der Spieler. Dass man sich da so zusammengerauft hat. Mittlerweile ist man jetzt auf Platz 13 und hat sechs Punkte Vorsprung wieder vor einem Abstiegsplatz. Das ist noch keine Ruhekissen, aber wie gesagt, man ist auf einem guten Weg. Die haben auch das Potenzial und die gehören auch einfach da irgendwo in das gesicherte Mittelfeld, würde ich sagen. Wobei das in England natürlich, wenn man sieht, dass Tottenham, Arsenal und Everton, Mannschaften, die noch viel, viel mehr Geld haben als Haussenden, dass die sich da auch in den ähnlichen Regionen tummeln, dann werte das die Arbeit von Hasenhüttl dann nochmal auf.
Absolut. Und gerade punkte technisch liegt man gerade schon genau im Mittelfeld. Es sind 6 Punkte nach oben auf Manchester United auf Tabellenplatz 5 und eben die von dir angesprochenen 6 Punkte nach unten auf Eston Villa. Und hätte man dieses Spiel gegen die Wanderers jetzt am Wochenende nicht verloren, dann hätte man sogar schon den Anschluss nach oben haben können. Wenn ich mir die Mannschaft angucke, dann sticht da Danny Ings raus, der mit 14 Treffern der erfolgreichste Torschütze ist und zwar mit weitem, weitem Abstand vom nächsten Schützen, der dann erst 4 Treffer hat. Ist denn, dass der Fußball den Ralph Hasenhüttl da spielen lässt, auch das, was wir von ihm gesehen haben in Leipzig und in Ingolstadt, also sehr hochpressen, sehr vertikales Spiel, sehr auf den Umschaltmoment hin ausgelegt oder hat es auch eine Entwicklung genommen?
Ja, das muss ja eine Entwicklung nehmen, in dem Sinne, dass wir es bei Liverpool thematisiert haben, nicht immer nur Plan A aus der Schublade ziehen kann, auf den sich dann erstens alle leicht einstellen oder relativ leicht einstellen können und B ist es ja auch dann für die eigene Mannschaft dann irgendwann, ja, stößt man an Grenzen in den Spielen und deswegen muss man ja immer mehrere Optionen haben, wie man spielt. Sie können auch variieren, sie können auch aus der tieferen Position heraus kontern, sie können auch, das machen sie auch gerade dann gegen Spitzenmannschaften, auch mal mutig vorne drauf gehen und die dann auch vor Probleme stellen, die sie gar nicht erwartet haben. Eine Schlüsselrolle dort als zentraler Mittelfeld nimmt noch Pierre-Emile Heubier ein, der ja auch aus der Bundesliga bekannt ist, der da auch Liederfunktion hat in zentraler Rolle. Danny Ings hast du schon gesagt, McAfee ist ein guter Torwart, der ihn auch schon einiges in schwieriger Phase gerettet hat. Das ist schon eine Mannschaft, die ja, das sind jetzt keine Superstars, dann wären sie auch, wie gesagt, wenn sie mehr Geld hätten, hätten sie mehr Stars usw. Aber das ist auch gar nicht das, was Hasenhüttl unbedingt will und anstritt, sondern er will Spieler entwickeln, er will Spieler besser machen und das eben trotzdem vor dem Hintergrund, dass man in der Premier League natürlich von heute auf morgen auf einmal auch mit einer relativ guten Mannschaft in Nöte geraten kann. Everton ist zum Beispiel vom Potenzial her noch viel besser besetzt und stand lange Zeit auch recht richtig schlecht da, hat sich jetzt erst auch unter Ancelotti stabilisiert. Also sprich, das kann in der Premier League immer schnell mal passieren, nach oben wie nach unten, dass man da den einen oder anderen Lauf hat und dementsprechend ist das eine konstante gute Arbeit dort in Southampton, die aber natürlich Rückschläge dann auch einkalkuliert sind und die aber am guten Gesamteindruck und am Gesamtweg, den man da eingeschlagen hat, eben auch nichts ändern, sondern der wird weiter verfolgt dieser Weg und der wird auch denke ich über kurz oder lang, wenn sich Erfolg einstellt, auch interessant werden für weitere junge Spieler und dann kann man den fortsetzen und wie gesagt auch taktisch dann eben variabel zwischen, das variiert zwischen Pressing und eben auch, man muss auch, wie gesagt, es gibt ja noch, nicht falsch verstehen, aber es gibt noch einige schlechte Gemeinschaften, sonst würden wir ja auch nicht weiter unten stehen, ohne dass ich jetzt damit sagen will, dass Hasenhüttl schlecht ist, aber es gibt eben einige, die die ganz andere Nöte haben und gegen die muss man dann auch logischerweise mal das Spiel machen und auch da muss man gewappnet sein. Und diese Möglichkeit hat es auch, Senden, aber natürlich ist die Kernkompetenz weiterhin, dass man selber kontert, was auch in den meisten Spielen dann auch möglich ist und dann auch sehr erfolgreich praktiziert wird.
Allein Thomas, als du gesagt hast, Everton-Trainer Carlo Ancelotti, da habe ich mir spontan gewünscht, wir könnten noch eine weitere Stunde dranhängen an diesem Kurzpass. Das ist einfach irre, was in der Premier League schon wieder alles passiert ist in den letzten Monaten, obwohl es auf den ersten Blick ja doch so aussieht, als hätte sich gar nicht so viel getan. Aber wie immer ist das nur der oberflächliche Blick. Für den Moment würde ich aber sagen, besser kommen wir jetzt in der kurzen Zeit, die wir in einem Kurzpass haben, nicht durch die Liga. Ich danke dir ganz, ganz herzlich, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast und mit mir zusammen ja dann quasi wieder den Wiederauftakt der internationalen Kurzpässe zelebriert hast, möchte ich fast schon sagen. Danke dir, lieber Thomas. Das war Thomas Böker vom Kicker. Ich hoffe, euch hat die Folge gefallen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr könnt unter kiosk.rasenfunk.derasenfunkmerch kaufen. Ihr könnt uns auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen, finanziell unterstützen. Dann bleiben wir weiter werbesponsoren und paywall frei. Und ab jetzt soll es dann auch wieder regelmäßig weiter gehen. Wenn alles gut geht, hört ihr jetzt wieder wöchentliche Kurzpässe zu interessanten Ligen. Habt eine gute Zeit. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Ciao.